Hi, my name is Philip Colbert.
This is my exhibition, Lobsteropolis, at Saatchi Gallery.
It's the world's first show utilizing tele-present robots for a private view.
It's a world first.
This is something completely different...
...because you can control yourself how you're moving through an exhibition...
...and it's really the closest thing that,...
...it places being in the exhibition space yourself physically.
So, it's actually very exciting now that we can't move...
...and we can't be everywhere at the same time.
This is a wonderful way of attending an auction preview or an exhibition preview...
...and you can get close up to the artwork.
You can have a look at it from near, from far...
...and you get a thing of proportion, so it's a pretty cool way of looking at art.